wall-e congratulations that was amazing
great job wall and Kid Flash let him
know that's how it's done
we just deposited plunder in iron
Heights yes you did
his real name is Jared Murillo turns out
he's wanted for a string of robberies
from here to Star City wall-e
what was that I mean you're supposed to
be shadowing me wait you're mad at me I
thought observe and learn that's it whoa
that's it bear ease up wall I just saved
your life I'm sorry Wally but if you
can't learn to follow orders this deal
between us it's over okay who's ready
for man Wallace
ba you're supposed to be dressed for the
museum opening it's over speedsters we
have time nobody likes a braggart yeah
but we were actually talking about
something important before you showed
out its own you okay you clean up well
thank you I like the way you dress guys
this is a very very big deal for all of
us come on don't be late to the Paula
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so we already
got some footage for the next episode of
the flash so let's break it out also
remind everyone what's going on with the
schedule there is a new round of the
flash ring giveaway going on right now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video make sure you click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
during the break just at first glance
this is a really simple scene about
Barry
training Wally West Wally not listening
just like Jesse quick Jessie totally did
not listen to Barry when he tried to
train her during the mirror master fight
so what's happening here is that while
he's just super eager and Barry is so
weighted down with all the crap that he
knows is going to happen because of
sabotage that it's causing him to be a
bit of an so what you need is
like a Jay Garrick type person to come
in and just tell them all to chill the
frak down but HR comes in and says the
museum's getting ready to open remember
he's trying to turn STAR Labs into a
museum which sounds like a precursor to
the flash Museum so we know that's going
on but the title of the episode is
borrowing problems from the future so
that is more of a hat tip to the other
big thing in this that they kind of
casually drop which is plunder another
Geoff Johns wally west era villain which
we heard about when Barry travelled to
the future so they're literally
borrowing a character problem from the
future there's probably some other stuff
happening to inform the title too but
that's the only thing we can guess based
on this clip so the thing about him is
that he actually makes me wonder if
they're going to do the Wunderland
arc from the Geoff Johns run which is a
Wally West story so way back in the
early 2000s a long time before Geoff
Johns ever brought Barry Allen back in
the first flash rebirth I know it gets
confusing when we talk about rebirth
because they have the new DC rebirth
going on right now with its own flash
rebirth so the original flash rebirth is
the first time Barry Allen came back but
before then for almost like eight or
nine years Geoff Johns wrote a lot of
Wally West's stories in plunder debuted
as a rogue during an arc called
Wonderland so Wally West gets trapped in
the mirror universe where he doesn't
have his powers and everything is
different it's like a darker version of
our reality so it's kind of like a
version of Earth
from the flash TV show season 2 where
zoom had taken control and all the metas
were evil so wall Wally West is trapped
powerless in this mirror universe being
arrested by the police
the Rogues send plunder back to the
regular universe to cause a bunch of
havoc and make a big distraction while
they take care of Wally West so what
they might do because we haven't done
mirror world yet is they might use a
multiverse story or they might choose
not to do that at all like they'll just
bring plunder on and he'll be a
distraction for something much bigger
because plunder is like a regular bounty
hunter he's dangerous but he usually
works with someone else there's somebody
else using him as a distraction so that
could be the other flash rogues or it
could be saboteur because with exception
to alternate earth stories like Gorilla
Grodd or any like the special small arcs
that are going to do sabotage the big
villain so one of the smaller villains
is going to be working for another big
villain that big villain is probably
going to be sabotage but one of the
other things that made me think of the
Geoff Johns Wonderland arc is because
there's this image on the cover of the
first issue of flash getting carted off
to prison we've never heard of the flash
we're taking you to jail and he doesn't
have his powers so he gets stuck in
prison he just has to rot there for a
little while till he can get out when
Barry ran back to save his mother at the
end of season 1 we saw a flash-forward
of him in prison that could be how he
ends up in prison but the thing I don't
think they'll do is mirror world they
might just use an alternate earth or
they might find some way for Barry to
lose his powers briefly or somehow just
end up in prison it's just that usually
the stand-in for mirror world is like
another earth so like we're going to go
to earth 19 eventually we've been to
earth 3 they might just use another
earth instead of doing straight-up
mirror world from the comics but I know
a lot of you are asking about the
prophecy thats avatar gave them like
somebody's going to betray them
someone's going to suffer a fate worse
than death someone will fall so I'm
going to do a separate video about that
but I do not think that Wally is going
to betray the team I think it'd be super
disingenuous for Wally to go through
this entire arc about getting his powers
back like almost betraying the team to
become one of sabotage followers they
save him
for him to then just turn around later
into the exact same thing so we can talk
about it a little more in the future but
just expect a betrayal from someone that
you would not think to betray the team
usually that's what they do each new
season is that a character surprises you
like Kaitlyn sweetest person ever gets
her killer frost arc almost turns on the
team in a later season
Cisco almost turns on the team when he
finds out that he might get his brother
back but then he comes back from the
edge of darkness so if someone else on
Team flash is going to betray them just
expect it to be a surprise somebody that
you wouldn't think would normally betray
them but if you guys want I will do a
flash Wonderland bonus video for like
that entire comic book story and they
also revealed you know big thing
gypsy from the comics is coming on the
show now her name is Cindy Reynolds so
that's probably what they'll call her
when she comes on the show but her
powers are basically like illusion
casting she can cause you to see things
but she could like camouflage herself in
any environment and someone that's
standing next to her so that's probably
how they're going to use her powers but
during the new 52 more recently she
showed up during a vibe arc in the actor
who plays Cisco revealed that she was
coming on the show so she might have
something to do with like a small arc
for Cisco's character in the back half
they didn't say exactly when she's
coming on but it's going to be somewhere
during the middle of the run in the back
half when we come back so that's just
one character I know a lot of you guys
have asked me for a video on the
accelerated man he's the flash from
earth 19 they're going to go to earth 19
it'll be a gorilla grodd crossover story
so they'll be all kinds of new stuff
happening that we haven't even learned
about in the back half of the season
that I'll talk more about when they
start to reveal stuff but just a
reminder the flash is coming back
January 24th I'll be doing flash ring
giveaway xand bonus videos every week so
no worries is going to be a lot of fun
so hopefully you guys are on break if
you're not caught up on all the DC shows
I would recommend you do that during the
break I have videos for pretty much
everything and what's happening later
tonight is I'll post my spider-man Q&A
video so if you haven't seen the
spider-man trailers I've posted check
those out and leave some comments if you
want me to include them in that QA while
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for my spider-man trailer
videos and you can click
here to learn all about saboteur on the
flash thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight